Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, Come on, let's go.
Come on, hey.
Come
back, everybody.
Thank you.
So much for the family, you gifted.
What the heck.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Gosh, thank you so much.
We're here at the finale of The Walking Dead Season 1.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
Because I think I'm gonna cry.
I mean, that was my birthday.
I hope there aren't too many waterworks.
Melody, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Do I need tissues?
Oh, wait.
Wait, hold on.
I was like, wait, I saw tissues earlier.
I forgot to pick them up.
I think I dropped them earlier.
Wait, hold on.
How am I supposed to reach?
Okay.
Okie dokie.
So, last time,
Uh...
We went to...
I keep wanting to call it Ravenholm.
But it's definitely not that.
We went to...
Craw...
Crawfish.
Crawford?
Craw...
Something.
Crow...
Crawford.
We went to Crawford.
And...
Um...
They were all taken over.
Whomp, womp.
And then we meet some new people.
And one of them dies.
Uh-oh.
One guy doesn't like us.
And he saw a horde of zombies coming in.
And they booked it out.
They left.
They took everything and left.
Almost missed the stream because I decided to take a nap after work.
Otoo!
Let's get Clem back.
Yeah!
Whoa.
Oh yeah, Clem was taken by the guy on the radio.
We still don't know who that is.
And you let Ben die, right?
Ben is unfortunately still alive.
I was too chicken to kill that guy.
I'm kind of interested in how else he'll mess up, quite honestly.
I'm interested.
This guy is like a walking death flag.
Everybody around him just...
Everybody dies.
His best friend, his teacher died.
Kenny's family.
I mean, the guy just sucks.
It boggles my mind.
They had the survivalist culpa with enforced abortions.
That's the opposite of survival.
Yeah, they were like no babies.
No babies, no old people.
I get the no old people.
But no babies?
I don't really understand it.
Maybe because they'll cry.
You can't be stealthy with a baby.
Huh.
I'm not quite sure.
I think they're silly people.
And now they're all zombie people.
More babies is more mouths to feed.
I mean, yeah.
But if you have like a whole school.
like you can you can make a garden you can you can grow your own food the ground isn't isn't bad it's not infected i think
but uh we found a boat we did find a boat and unfortunately also lee got bitten was it bitten or like scratched it didn't really look like a bite mark no old people like how old exactly no hags everybody disliked that oh it is a bite okay he got chopped
so we know how this is we know a little bit of how this is gonna end and i'm so sad oh it is intended to be a bite i see
Who's your favorite character so far?
And who's your least favorite?
Ben incoming.
No, I disliked that girl's dad more than Ben.
Test this with a whisp-softboard server.
Larry, yeah.
I disliked Larry more than I disliked Ben.
Larry was just insufferable.
That guy only wanted to fight.
That guy sucked.
And then...
My favorite character.
I think Clementine's too easy of a choice.
I really liked Molly.
I wish she would have stuck around for more.
We met her last episode.
It's hard because all my friends are dying.
to be sure we get a character and then i really liked um oh my gosh what was her name the love interest for lee carly i liked her a lot too recently i heard your disappointment at lack of marriage proposals wait luckily for you per the recent economic downturn i find it advantageous to ask for your hand in marriage what does that mean
Doug?
I don't think we got to know Doug well enough.
Wait, so would Doug have been shot instead of Carly in that one scene if we took him instead?
Nah, well, thank you so much for the video!
Thank you!
What the heck, thank you!
Playing 400 days in the other three seasons.
I don't know what that is.
But, oh, you mean of this game?
of the Walking Dead?
400 days is post-game DLC.
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Give me them sweet tax breaks, Mickey.
Wait, do married people get tax breaks?
Wait, seriously?
Wait.
Yes?
That's why people get married.
I thought people got married because they liked each other.
Wait!
What?
Oh, if you have babies.
I'm a ghost.
How would...
You know what?
I'm not gonna think about it.
We never decided our wedding date.
Wait, don't forget about us.
Don't forget about me!
Orca!
I'm waiting, Orca!
Come on!
Okay.
tax breaks may not be the only reason i thought people got married because they liked each other they're doing it for the sweet cash oh my gosh
oh wow or you know um what's it called for like uh
For power.
You know, if you're like, oh, we must have our kingdoms unite.
Hey, Mint, want to get some tax breaks together?
Political marriage, yeah.
Oh, wow.
I didn't know that.
Wait, you have to have a baby?
Or you would have you just say, I'm going to have one.
What if you just trick them?
You say, I'm going to have a baby.
You can file jointly if you're married and get a tax break, even with no kids!
Oh my gosh.
That's called tax fraud.
No, it's not.
How would you have babies?
Well, it's been 38 weeks since your Christmas karaoke, so in two more weeks.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Yeah, it's September.
It's September.
Guys, this is not the conversation we should be having before this very sad episode, About tax breaks and babies.
How do we talk about this again?
We talked about babies because of Crawford.
Lee, who?
We need the distraction.
Okay, that's fair.
This episode is not sad, surely.
It's going to be so fine.
I bet probably they will discover the cure for the dead, for the zombie disease right now.
And also And also, the next three seasons, it's four seasons, right?
The next three seasons will just be slice of life.
Guaranteed.
Duck and Kacha come back.
Yeah, actually, they weren't shot with real bullets.
It was...
I swallowed my spit rock.
They were just...
They were...
Paint bullets.
Which one hurts more?
Airsoft or...
Paint.
What's it called?
Uh...
Paintball.
Paintball by far?
Paintball?
More.
Paint hurts way more.
Well, yeah.
Depends on the PSI.
That makes sense.
Turns into a baseball sim as close.
Clem and Lee play catch for four games.
It'll be like an awesome...
It'll turn into like a shonen...
Not shonen.
Like a sports anime.
If he would save Doug, Lily would have aimed for Ben instead, but Doug would have jumped in front and took the bullet for him killing.
He's...
He's too good of a man!
We saved him from such a sad fate of protecting Ben!
You know what?
Doug!
Alright, let's play the game.
Thank you guys for all this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning, Ryder!
Oh my gosh, I started the new Common Ryder today!
Oh, it's so good!
It's so good, it's so fun.
Oh my gosh, I highly recommend.
I've been watching it, uh, the, uh...
Uh...
I've been watching it.
And, um...
I don't know how I feel about the new suit, but I really like it.
Shiyakusa!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Zets!
Yeah, Kamen Rider Zets.
It's so cool.
it's really fun i i recommend i like the new take on the belt oh the gotcha is so funny
yeah the gotcha is funny um i like the belt it's it's interesting it seems kind of like new age i suppose i'm not i like common rider but i would not say i'm like a super duper huge fan so like you know i just haven't watched a ton of it but i do like what i what i watched so you need to hear your thoughts on the bike robot man he's so funny
we need your henshin henshin
dog thank you for the thank you okay i was gonna start and then you got I mean, talking about...
I mean, talking about...
about...
Common Rider.
I was just watching it today, so it's like fresh in my brain.
Okay, let's do this!
Play.
Oh.
I don't like that.
Played this game up to this chapter, then stopped.
Look forward to seeing how it all ends.
I guess we'll find out.
previously no time left more like no one left i know my parents come home and i'm not there i've got my walkie-talkie lucky thanks for the fact that way hey there were some batteries in one of those boxes here you can have some too oh we're seeing we'll be in savannah we're seeing like the whole thing about the radio they always stay in the same place when they go there the marsh house yes that's it you didn't come into town from the railroad did you We gotta go!
Yup.
Oh, Winchuck!
Clementine?
Clementine!
Clementine's gone.
Wherever she is, I have to find her.
We have a better chance of finding her if we all go together.
Who's with me?
We'll look for Clementine together.
Thank you for the five gift advice.
Thank you.
What kind of friend would I be if I wasn't there for you now?
Maybe you should stay with the boat.
Okay, sure.
Quit?
Clementine.
No way.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, the Zombo is following from the train.
Oh, my God.
Vernon, get out here.
There doesn't have to be any trouble here.
All I want is the girl.
her back and nobody needs to get hurt where are you where are you vernon you son of a bitch who is this it's not vernon if that's what you're thinking and you should really watch your tone
i choose my next words very carefully what do you want for me whatever it is i'll do it You can let her go.
I want you to never hurt anybody again.
This isn't a kidnapping, Lee.
I'm going to hurt you.
What is it?
A rescue?
Gosh!
Dang it!
I knew it!
Ugh!
Hold on.
I'm coming for you, Clem!
Run.
Borrow time.
Looks an awful like, like, kidnapping.
I know, right?
Oh, don't look at it.
How's that feeling?
It tingles.
Uh, fine.
Fine.
Don't worry about it.
It wasn't a full chunk.
They will remember that.
It wasn't.
We don't have much time.
It wasn't a full chop.
What?
Why didn't you shut the door?
Okay, now you can shut the door.
We'll all make sure nothing gets in.
There you go.
Kenny...
Try to find another way out of here.
Okay, Kenny has some sense.
Oh, okay.
Let's look at the coolers.
It was a nibble.
Just a little.
Damn.
I was kind of hoping they dug some secret tunnels or something.
Crystal, you have a second?
We'll have time to chit chat later.
Okay, you're right.
Omid.
There's thousands of dead filling the sewers and God only knows how many up top, so...
Well, let them fill the sewers and then they can't get out, huh?
Can't those things let up for a fucking minute?
Just keep looking for another way out.
I got this.
Yeah, Leah is a professor.
That's so true.
I keep looking for a way out.
Yeah, get to it.
I am.
Okay.
Anything over here?
Walking to, uh, operating table?
I can't.
Where the hell did they go?
Stop mumbling.
The zombies are so loud.
I can't hear anything.
Anything?
A key?
No.
Nothing?
Oh, what is that?
What is that?
A real?
spreader looks like a car jack I don't want to imagine this being used on a body I like when I hear like one zombie really clearly he'll just be like just some surgical supplies interesting okay what's in this cabinet nothing okay oh the scale this is a I want to know how skinny I am I want to know how skinny I am look at the elevator hey I think I found a way out does it who's so who's who's talking over there chit-chatting up a storm open the elevator shoot the elevator yeah Exactly.
The yapping dead.
Okay.
Crank it.
I'll have these doors open in two seconds.
One.
Two.
I hope nobody's in there.
Are you okay?
Wait.
Oh, Lee?
Oh.
Lee?
It's not looking so good.
Fuck.
Is he alive?
Shit.
This is bad.
Hello.
Okay.
Maybe it's a tummy ache.
This has to be done.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait!
I'm awake!
Stop!
He's awake!
He's still bitten.
So?
This is about trying to save him.
At the very least, buy him some time.
Oh, wait, actually, yeah, do that.
Cut off my arm.
Do we know it works?
Okay, but it's, like, totally spread through my system now at this point.
We know there's going to be a lot of blood.
There's going to be a shitload of blood.
What if he dies?
Then the rest of us go after Clementine and get the hell out of Savannah.
Uh...
Damn right.
been way too long if there's a chance it stops you from turning uh we have to take it i don't know oh i missed my chance sorry what do you think i think it's been way too long we leave it we leave it are you sure yeah i feel like i got time just keep an eye on me i get my hands there's no way that it's not entirely in my system like come on you're gonna die yeah But not in here.
You guys keep an eye on that door.
I'll work on getting us out of here.
We?
No.
This is what we're doing, and I don't want to hear anything else, okay?
But also, I don't want to be an injured man.
They'll smell my blood.
Like, there's...
We've already established that they could smell that, no?
Like, it would be so stupid to cut off my arm.
Am I still doing this?
And we'll be weak?
It'll be so stupid!
Hey!
We did it.
All right.
Up we go.
We're gonna have to go as quiet as possible and see if we can make it to an empty floor or even the roof.
Sounds good.
Oh.
Scary.
Liquid's dog's arms.
Everybody has a replacement.
There's some light up there.
Good.
Gotta get my ass off this ladder.
With darkness and silence.
What?
What was it?
Night.
What a thrill.
Why did we stop?
Oh.
Watch out!
That was fucking close.
Everything okay up there?
Oh, just fucking peachy.
Oh, I'm still moving.
I'm searching and I'm melting to you.
I'm still going.
What a fear in my heart.
No!
Oh, this is so bad.
Lee!
Oh, God.
Are you alive?
Get up!
Ah!
I'm alive.
You have to pull yourself up.
I got it.
I got this.
It's just a sit-up.
We got this.
Let's go.
Good job.
How?
Oh my gosh.
How did his legs lock like that?
Crunch time.
Yeah.
Wow, that's a really cool visual.
Wait, that's...
Why are there so many?
Yeah, that would have been way harder with one arm, huh?
Us losing blood?
No help.
Yeah, it was a hospital, so this place is...
When they were like, we need to find an empty floor, I was like, in a hospital?
You got that zombie strength.
Remember when Savannah was empty?
And the zombie speed.
Those Crawford bastards did.
one thing right I guess yeah there must be thousands of them they didn't follow no out today it sure seems like it that's crazy they can't track they just roam is it that fucking train wasn't exactly Clementine's out there Clementine's out there somewhere gobbled up in all of that we'll get to her Lee we'll do whatever we have to look let's get our bearings and see if we can figure out a way to town good good i don't think we can ignore what just happened to lee oh that he's he's right he's right i was showing off i'm gonna be honest it's the bite just have to deal with it you gotta let us know if you start feeling funny you know i know it's just dissonance that's all i'm all good new fan as you can yeah good as i can be I'm thinking about it,
but I'm really enjoying this one.
Right, pal?
Now, let's get our bearings.
You're the bell tower.
You distract them all with that, right?
Yeah, don't do it.
All the paint.
Like Molly did, yeah.
Some poor bastard took a spill.
Yeah, looks like whoever was up here painting that sign went ass over tea kettle.
Oh, poor guy.
It's an extension ladder.
That might be helpful for the...
The bell.
Oh, I know.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I was stuck on...
Oh.
He or she walked away from whatever accident happened.
Well, that doesn't really mean much.
oh oh gosh so they fell and then they were covered in oh gosh oh that's pretty bad canny that looks like Crawford Square over there fuck that place yeah did fix up our boat though we get Clementine and get right back make sure she wears her life jacket okay something tells me she's not gonna Oh,
we're not going on the boat!
Oh!
I think my thing is bugged.
Wait, it keeps saying look at footprints.
Okay, now it's changed.
I bet that hurt like hell.
Okay, there we go.
Because it just kept saying look at footprints.
Krista!
That's the church across the street from the mansion.
River Street should be just beyond that we need to head back that way we'll stop off at the mansion like you said and make sure we didn't overlook anything I think we've checked everything in that house like a billion times I think we've checked that spot that house like we've we have really picked it clean I think I think there's nothing left what's up over here Bell Tower that's what's up yeah that could help when I'm bod gang I'm going to see if I can sing all of snake eater during that part would be funny if the developers did that okay so let's go get the ladder right right hey hey oh oh there's more how's the leg how's the leg it's doing a lot better thanks for going into Crawford for me even if it wasn't for me Clementine too she's tough as hell oh me's nice yeah everybody's gonna die shit about her okay legs oh wow that's way further than I thought it was wait that's a pretty big gap I'll see if we can make it out to that bail tower okay be careful though I don't want you going
any sooner than you have to thanks I
favorite you know that really yeah she's a big fan you get away with shit i never would how we're getting her back lee you know that wait how like what i've not seen anything of the sword we'll get out of sight and leave you with him clem's ocean i get you okay can we talk to crystal again talk to everybody else he's not looking so good he's got that gamer posture Krista!
Anything over here?
Honestly, my vision isn't great.
I think it's allergies or all that shit those walkers are kicking up.
Oh no.
Allergies, that's funny.
How's that funny?
People used to get those.
People still get those.
You never see anybody in an end of the world story with pay fever.
It's not the time to get wistful.
I know.
It's this deal with Clem.
It's everything.
Put Ui-sensei's stance.
Just put this rage inside me like I can't even say.
I used to get allergies too, and just...
Fuck.
Who was that guy?
Someone with priorities?
Any thoughts about the herd?
Got any good ideas for getting through that, uh, herd?
I'm working on it.
Are you gonna be able to hang in there?
I have to.
I'm hanging.
There's a bell tower.
The mansion's that way.
Yeah.
If we can use that bell tower to bring them to that side of the hospital it won't be an easy trip back toward river street but it wouldn't be impossible yeah i'm with you just have to get over there yeah i was thinking you and omid wouldn't come with me we look out for each other but we sure as hell weren't gonna let you go alone not with that time bomb chewed into your wrist you two have been solid since day one what's this day three poor yeah i appreciate it it feels like months oh my gosh how long so uh it's only been a couple months right because we've seen like day 80 whatever what so they literally have only been with us for a couple of days hello
see anything nah i'm just uh i was taking a minute actually no kenny sorry i know i shouldn't what's going on what do you mean what's going on there's just a lot going on
everything fuck man you know I do I can't thank you enough for what you did for duck I don't know how I'd be if you hadn't don't dwell on it I look at where we are right now and I can't imagine cat duck and all this mess yeah no no I'm sorry we're in a fucking hurry to get off this roof it's it's not the time I'm sorry i'm okay how many you think are below me you think are wandering around underneath us right now can you in the hospital thousands i mean who knows was full of dead before right yeah that's what yeah he lost his wife his kid and now his friend look at that dust fuck man who knows did you see the bell tower mansions that way bell towers over there if we go down the opposite be able to make it without too much trouble i can do that yeah yeah what do you think any thoughts about anything else nah i'm all right just needed to take a second i'll keep an eye out over here sorry oh kitty oh kitty he's uh he's uh what the that was strange that was not me moving my mouse game is
bugged game is haunted um uh what was i saying
Kenny is a strong-headed character, but he does not seem to be a bad character, you know?
Game is infected.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
All right.
The bells.
Could buy us some time.
Draw as many as we can this way.
Get down off the roof on the opposite side and bust our asses getting back to the mansion.
You think you should be the one to go?
my leg's feeling better let me do it oh man we have to decide who takes a risk like this it should be the guy who's got the least to lose what's the worst that could happen I get bitten again
too soon oh here I go all right
hurry okay yeah what she said it should be fine I'm going.
Climb to the bell tower.
What's the worst that can happen?
This seems pretty sturdy, no?
Oh, I lied.
I lied, I lied.
No one's holding the ladder.
Holy shit, man.
Are you okay?
Um...
Yeah.
I'm fine.
Try to find another way out of there?
I jinxed it.
A few solid rings of this, and there'll be thousands down below.
But that's the only way we can get out!
Why wouldn't anyone hold it?
It wouldn't have fallen.
It wouldn't have fallen if somebody was holding it.
Like, it might have broke still, but it wouldn't have dropped to the ground.
Oh, no.
No, no.
It's locked.
Shit.
The exit in here's locked.
Uh-oh.
Um.
Uh.
All moonwalk?
Alright, let's pull the rope.
Oh, my ears.
I wonder where Molly went.
I guess she left, left, but like, where'd she go?
It was like when everyone was just standing around.
They're coming this way.
He was beating up the one guy.
Tons of them.
Jesus.
Now get back here.
How?
You gonna catch me in your arms?
Oh, big boy.
The ladder's down there!
I think I have to jump.
There's no way back.
You can make it.
It ain't that far.
You got this.
You got this, motherfucker.
Yeah, pep talk, pep talk.
Alright.
What does that mean?
Oh.
Kenny!
I'm gonna jump into your arms.
Don't look down!
Oh, don't look...
Why would you say that?
You got it, Lee!
Here I go!
Kenny, catch me in your big, strong arms!
Not a single person to help him up.
Good goddamn leap, pal.
Wow, okay.
roof all right why did nobody help why did nobody help him wow that was brutal
no help i took it so seriously oh is that come on please ben what
are you doing don't get mad The boat's gone.
No, shit, it's gone.
Ben, what happened?
They were waiting for me in here.
Vernon, his whole crew.
Yes, Clementine with them?
No.
He seemed pissed you guys lost her, and...
Well, they took it.
They're gone.
Ben, you are worthless.
How's Lee feeling?
Don't change the subject.
Oh.
I can't believe you didn't even put up a fight.
Wow, they took the boat.
Oh, Mead, can you go over the fence and let us into the backyard?
You shouldn't be out in the open.
Yeah.
I can't believe Vernon's crew took the boat.
This is not happening.
Everything is so fucked.
Clementine is still out there.
So we get Clementine and then what?
Yeah.
We get the fuck out of cities.
I'm done with cities.
We go into the countryside and make a go of it.
Yeah, that seems like a good idea to me.
This is so bad.
You just did.
Don't get fucking smart with me, Ben.
Tell.
remember we had a boat a boat let's just get over it everyone keep it together get over it then I mean immediately we stay the course don't turn on each other yeah chill out Kenny chill out Kenny I should have killed him Ben I swear to God what do we do without a boat um get another Fuck,
get to the countryside maybe?
Get to the countryside.
Dicked around with cities and coastlines and boats too long.
Yeah, if we're a boat, where do we go for that too, you know?
Like, I never really kind of understood the plan.
I agree with you.
I think out in the country is the safest place to be.
We'll get over it.
But you're not dead yet.
So put a pin in that, okay?
Where the hell do you get off?
I'm just saying we should all chill.
Not just you.
Chill?
Bandits?
Hey, chill!
Here's some pills.
Vernon, chill.
Here's our fucking boat.
This isn't my fault.
I can't point to one thing that's happened that isn't somehow your fault.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, tell him.
Lee should have left you and Crawford.
Oh, you, Kenny.
Oh, whoa, Ben.
Whoa, Ben.
No, let him.
Oh, what?
I am so, so, so sorry about Kachi.
Why are we letting Ben go off of Kenny?
And I know I fucked up, but stop pushing me around.
and stop wishing I was dead.
Then give me a reason to wish you were alive!
You said goodbye.
I never got to see my family.
My parents, my little sister.
Do you get that?
Your family is gone, but at least you had them to lose.
I never made it home.
They could be alive or dead or walkers or worse, and I don't know.
So give me a fucking break!
Oh, Ben.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Here they come.
Here they come, Ben.
I get that Ben's a teenager.
They shouldn't be able to get into the backyard, right?
I get that, Ben.
Maybe not.
We can secure this place.
It's a teenager, but he...
Weapons.
Search the house for weapons.
Wait, that was a terrible...
There is nothing...
Wait, there's...
Kenny.
Kenny, move furniture.
Move anything you can up against the doors and windows.
That's what I was thinking.
But he's...
Oh, uh...
Kill anything...
Kill anything that gets in.
You know you're talking to me, right?
Ben, just do it.
He needs to prove himself!
Omid?
What is it?
Oh, shoot.
Front doors!
Oh, that's the sickest dog door!
Oh, my gosh.
Lee, help!
Cut the fucking arm.
Oh.
There's gotta be a knife or something in there.
A knife?
Wait, where'd the dog food go?
Uh, drawer?
Nothing.
Drawer?
Knife.
Oh!
That's, that's handy.
Take your goddamn arms off!
Yeah!
Watch your, watch your fingers!
Oh, come on.
That, that it?
Oh.
Okay, that was close.
Now what?
Okay.
Uh, get ready to fight.
Get ready to fight.
This place seems sturdy to me.
I think we're fine.
Good job, Krista.
Krista.
Sturdy my ass.
Get up there!
Go!
No way!
It's Bree!
No!
Guys, help me with this!
how'd she get all the way here oh again
everyone get to the end of the hallway oh no more what do we do now this will fall down we're working on it the end of the hallway and take a fucking stand why are there so many many as we can.
When we see an opening, we go for it.
Left for dead moment.
Yeah.
Three.
Five.
Four.
Two.
One.
Oh.
Hello?
Is it me?
I'll get him.
Uh, is anyone else gonna shoot?
Is anyone else gonna shoot?
Is that... Okay, nice.
Oh, I'm out?
I'm out!
Me too!
Uh-oh.
Fuck!
Where do we go?
There's no goddamn opening!
Oh!
Go!
Team, go!
Oh, no.
Okay, Ben, pull it up.
Good job.
Phew.
here um i'm not good with these you dropped it down there wait wait did he pick that up
what that could have gone better everyone okay lee's still bitten shut up i think honestly they should have keep moving from the get-go kids right we gotta keep moving think there's any chance we get clem and catch up to those goddamn thieves if you just leave and they don't hear anything they'll never come back we're not going out through this window no latches no roof access and 30 feet straight down anyone have any ideas I bet this guy would I was just looking at him Dixon Kent the third industrial mead Krista just trying to lighten the fucking tone we need solutions not stupid jokes hey I'm sorry uh so there's gotta be another way right it's gotta be another way event anything or we wait for the house to clear out and stick to the high ground that's what I feel whoa Lee you okay oh no yeah yeah I'm gonna have to just oh
Clem Clem Lee get up where was Oh me looking what did that mean she's at the hotel where her parents was staying he hasn't moved her yet yeah yet we need to start thinking about more than just clementine when it comes to our okay well that's fair what do you mean how do we get out of here that's true that's the whole point we don't know we figured it out now your life depends on it how do you get out of here i don't know i don't get it um i do wait what do you mean by that keep looking for a way needs to keep looking for a way out damn it we're trapped in here they will remember you think we have what i i don't know we should cut it off at least then there would have been a chance well you didn't and it's too late now i think we need to have an adult conversation about what happens if lee takes another spill oh hey look we could be looking at a larry situation here oh it's
We don't need to talk about it.
Oops, I tried to do it.
We're still reading them.
I'm not advocating anything here.
But how is this not a thing?
We're also worked up about Clementine that we're forgetting what the fuck happened to you.
My arm is...
My arm is not the issue.
I'm not the problem.
The 500 walkers in the house and no door in this room are the goddamn problems.
Yeah.
Maybe at the moment.
But who's to say when it becomes an issue?
At that point, there may not be any time left to deal with it.
is bloodthirsty you're gonna listen to me we will get clementine back with or without you because i haven't given up everything to die because we were stupid i'm sorry okay fuck we can't do this we're gonna have to what why am i taking this oh you ruined that dude's face shut up sweetie look There's another room.
It's corroded to hell.
What's on the other side of this wall?
A 30-foot drop?
No.
Wait, what is this?
This mansion butts up against the one next door.
I'll be damned.
This wall ain't shit.
Is this really possible?
Corroded.
Right?
Wouldn't it be like, what, dry-rodded instead?
Maybe not corroded.
I'm not a carpenter, though.
Okay.
You can't call me Sabrina.
Krista and I.
Lee, you rest.
We have to work fast.
I wasn't going to hurt you.
I want him to still be my friend.
Sure, pal.
I know.
One thing I do like about Kenny is he can dish it and he can also take it.
Like he's pretty forgiving for the most part.
I'm glad you told us when you got bitten.
It would have been easy not to.
Yeah.
Well.
You probably would have let you go alone if you hadn't told us.
Which would have been a mistake.
If I were you, I would have been scared shitless.
Um.
If you were me, you'd be a foot taller.
Hey.
And about 50 pounds heavier.
Wouldn't get scared as much.
With your arm and my leg.
I'll cripple fight you right here, buddy.
head to chop this one off for you to even stay in the chain wish you would have taken it off i don't think it matters much now i'm losing we love a short king really yeah it's hot
like it's asleep tingly i don't think it would have mattered what do you think
um we just get clementine we're just gonna get her despite how i feel i i can't let vengeance be sure but if it's not that easy we'll do whatever it takes and you know whatever happens to you seriously can we not talk like that I think it's the entire time we're at the hospital I could sense you think you're as good as dead I'm bitten Krista we all know that's a wrap yeah there's gotta be something the cure will happen in five seconds i want you guys to take her oh wait he means them to take oh the two of them no i meant like i'm serious she'd be safe and relatively happy with you too we're not doing this oh christine listen to him i thought they meant the group okay wait how about him uh what he um he'll figure it out What do you mean by that?
You either get his act together or something will happen to him.
Yeah.
That's it?
What else is there to say?
You lose his shit like that often?
No.
That was a first.
It's good that he did.
Kenny couldn't pull that shit on me.
The kid killed Kenny's family!
The kid killed his family.
So there's been some tension.
Yeah!
Really?
I think, um, he has a very valid reason to not like Ben.
Kenny's son got bitten during a raid by some gang that Ben was secretly helping.
help him they used him kenny's wife battle because of their son jesus yeah well seems like it got through to kenny um yeah he's pissing me off i'm out of gas you look good and rested sure if you don't count an infected leg you want me to do it you took some you can hop in after me oh it took some biotics fine it took some medicine welcome to my bush attack it shouldn't be long now it's good we're forced to take a breath i still can't believe you went and got chomped i went and got chomped man took some brass i don't think i would have oh really kenny meinto will remember that how are you i'm i don't know how to answer that i'm sorry you've lost more than anyone it'll be all right ken as much as anyone it'll be all right ken Acting like what's happened ain't happened.
Anyway, I appreciate it for both of you.
Aw.
A lot of us have lost families.
Some of us for reasons of people sitting in the room.
You're right to hate him.
I'm fueling the fire.
What good's it doing?
I'm not getting them back.
Everybody stares at him?
He's having a rough go.
Yeah.
Yeah, we all are!
I just...
Ugh!
What's that?
Juice?
This guy tell you much about what we've been through?
Bits and pieces.
Well, he can't fight for shit.
Well, look at him.
Hey!
What are you talking about?
Like you guys didn't have enough problems without punching each other in the face.
Yeah, he had to knock some scents into me before we met you on the train.
Clean and pristine his...
Why is?
Oh, wait, what do you say?
Uh...
After everything, you're still a bastard, don't you?
Been hearing that my whole life, Doc.
Well, that's how you know we're buddies.
I call him a bastard.
Cheers!
Save's Ben last time, so...
Yeah.
This, the alcohol will clean my system.
Oh, the baby.
Oh.
Don't- don't pressure her to drink.
Oh!
I'm through!
Well?
No walkers.
Things are looking up.
Yahoo!
Everyone keep a goddamn eye out.
Be your old clock, baby.
This place seems pretty sealed off.
Well.
Oh!
Oh.
Wait.
Um, let's keep moving.
What do you mean how could they do this?
I think...
Yeah.
There's an apocalypse.
There's so many people.
I don't know why these ones break my heart.
How did we not go into this room before?
It's not giving yourself a chance.
It's what Kacha did.
Oh.
I'm sorry, Kim.
Yeah, get the gun.
Take the gun.
She left me.
My son.
People that cared about us.
I forgive her, but it don't make it any less wrong.
You don't just end it because it's hard.
You stick it out and you help the folks you care about.
So let's figure a way out of here and get that little girl.
Yeah, think about Clementine.
Clementine got at least one shot left oh nice Kenny has some sense before we move on Lee figure out where we're headed I mean look on his face he looks content to me yeah let's keep at it I'm trying to try to lighten the moon you guys
Hard to believe the world once felt this peaceful.
Oh, Ben.
What do you got to say for yourself?
You still with a spit?
Yeah, Lee.
Nah, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
You okay?
You still with a spit?
Yeah, Lee.
I just want to help.
That's what he always says.
Shoshia, thank you so much for the 50 gifts.
Thank you.
What do you call this thing?
What do you call?
Why did he make that face?
Thank you so so much!
It's sick, but...
Think of all the pain they avoided.
Hmm...
Krista?
I guess Crawford would have gotten them anyway.
What they have?
They look able... They look like they're young and...
I actually can't tell.
Don't ask me how I'm doing.
keep going they don't look like they would have been thrown out but who knows what their criteria was
firefly hotel welcome back thank you she might have been gregna true she might have been all right so we have a balcony door wait let's just look out the door first might be the way out crawford still found so exactly so it doesn't really even matter Oh,
oh, wait, this is good.
Nothing other than personal items in here.
Not even a snack.
No chocolate under the undies.
Looks like we can stay off the streets all the way to River Street if we're careful.
Let's go.
Go ahead.
Oh, okay.
I'll go first.
You guys don't hide stuff underneath your panties?
I want Sith candy.
be at
my whole house.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Who hasn't jumped?
Okay.
Don't wait, Ben.
No, kidding.
No way.
Wait, where is... Oh, there he is.
Is he alive?
Me and my fucking mouth.
Wait.
Holy fuck.
What are we gonna do?
Gravity is a deadly...
Is he alive?
Kenny.
Uh, keep a lookout.
Stay up here.
Keep an eye out.
Okay, but I can't see much from up here.
Just let us know if they start coming down the alley.
We'll be back.
Be.
Careful.
I got ants in my pants.
Ants in my pants.
Ow.
I'm okay.
Stop yelling.
Please shut up, Ben.
I'm okay just get me out of here quiet being or they'll be on top of us yeah yeah try to keep your mouth shut I'm sorry just get me up my legs hurt I think I was one of the ants oh my god he landed on garbage really I thought you oh no
oh no he's got eva oh no oh no what is it I'm okay I'm okay no oh we can get you up we can uh oh oh
don't look at it uh he yeah uh he's gonna yell he could stay quiet it's quiet we could take our time and save his life shh shh shh i can be super quiet yeah be quiet oh oh they're smelling his they're smelling tasty fuck
oh oh god don't let them get to me um that's like really hard do you have any bullets left this has only got one left in it i'm out shit what get the fuck out of here what go back she needs you lee This is not a discussion!
Hell no!
Hell no, man!
I'm not leaving!
What did I just say?
Let's get Ben and get out of here!
What the fuck, can he?
Lee.
Lee, it's okay.
No, Kevin!
No, kid.
No, it's not!
It's just something I gotta do.
You know that.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Why?
why are you why are you there get that girl why don't you come with back you sons of bitches damn it kenny kenny god damn it kenny
over ben
What happened?
Um, weren't you on lookout?
You should know.
I tried.
They're gone.
Ben was not making an eye.
Ben was...
Damn!
Why, Kenny?
Why?
Kenny!
I heard a shot.
Why didn't he just shoot Ben and go?
Kenny made sure that Ben didn't feel any more pain than he had to.
Oh, over Ben.
What?
It was Ben's biggest fear you know Kenny had one bulletin.
That's how he used it God poor fucking kid
You saw them die Nobody was getting out of there What I'm sorry, Lee Maybe he got he wasn't a bad guy who we talking about here?
Wasn't a bad guy Kenyon a lot of folks might not have always agreed even me they will remember that we should go right behind you over bed
over bed
our friend do you want to talk our friend Kenny was my friend!
Kenny was my friend.
Soon as someone dies, they don't immediately have to have their sins forgiven.
What does that mean?
What?
I understand.
Look, Lee.
This is a shitty time.
But I want to clear something up.
What?
Now with Kenny, gone.
Means... Oh, Mead and I have to stay safe.
For her.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, you do.
Let me take all the risks.
That's not what I mean, necessarily.
It's what I mean.
It's what we gotta do.
Oh, this looks...
Be careful across here.
This doesn't look very safe?
Who built this?
Oh, golly.
That's a far drop.
Okay.
I'm ready for the QT.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, hi.
Oh,
I don't like to know.
I'm not afraid of heights, but this makes me a little uneasy.
Oh, okay.
Nothing bad happening.
It's surprising.
Whoa, careful.
What's going on in there?
The buildings are full.
Oh, my gosh.
I know where the next meal is.
uh be careful to be careful to yeah we don't need any more accidents it's a party i'm sorry it's okay oh ouch
oh do i go thank you so much for the vibe gifted thank you okay wow it's really is you can hear them it's so loud don't look down man oh my gosh Look how many there are!
Marshal's hotel is around the corner of the block.
Yeah, that's it.
We have to cross here.
Oh.
At least it doesn't look like a death trap.
Oh, meh.
Ha ha ha ha.
Goose, going first.
You're the lightest.
He's got a busted leg and you're walking for two.
Oh!
Wait, so he does know!
Wait!
When did we know?
when did we find out uh uh i'll i'll go first i'll go first in case anything happens out there you're sure yeah leah knew leah is smart did she say something i don't remember sorry if she did or not
i just remember her being upset about all the stuff There I go.
Just go nice and slow.
I like how we still have the cleaver on us.
That's pretty nice.
Oh, when do you think this was built?
In like the 1400s.
The 1900s.
It's an easy crossing.
Is it?
You should have gone on the other side where the balcony is, right?
I'm blocking it with my head, but...
it oh fuck oh my god are you okay at least the 1900s I'm kind of fucked here what are you gonna do um I'll figure something out I'll figure something out there's not a ton of options can you help me can you help me I don't know what we can do from here anything it's fucked lee uh i'm going for it i'm going for it i tried all my options what does that mean it means i'm already bitten i just have to push my way through what the fuck
uh let's meet outside of town by the train what are you nuts it's the only way do you hear me yeah by the train there were no boats so there's no point in looking for a boat
Wait, so is he going to...
Clam or...
You think the zombies won't bother me because I'm already bit?
Oh.
Wait, my cleaver.
What are you doing?
What's the idea here?
Lee, I'm scared.
Don't do it.
What a badass!
Yeah, baby!
She's too cool!
Ripa die!
Oh,
whoa.
Holy!
Oh my gosh!
Clean.
Now, thank you so much for the story!
Where did I go?
Oh, wow!
Do I recognize the car?
Was it the one we stole from?
That I didn't steal from.
But others did.
It's really quiet in here.
That was some nice ripping and tearing.
Thanks, Doomguy!
walking.
It could be a zombie, but I didn't hear zombie noises.
Oh.
Happy birthday, Nome King.
Ask me later, and I'll try and give some things.
Though I don't know Ikebukuro very well.
Oh!
Hello?
I got us adjoining rooms.
Uh, where is she?
Where is she?
I already told you she's fine.
Why does he look like Norman Bates?
You look horrible.
Go over there.
Um, I just dual wielded glass.
Put your things down.
Let me out.
Who's out there?
Clem!
Shh!
Quiet, please, sweetie.
Your things.
There.
I don't have anything.
I don't have anything on me.
Really.
You got all the way here without any weapons.
I lost them.
I don't believe you.
Oh, he's gonna hate me now.
Seriously!
Seriously.
You don't believe me?
Go ahead.
Search me.
no I'm not touching you just sit down nice we get my we get to keep my stuff let's go double down I am no actually no I don't know who you are I don't know anything about you who are you what you wouldn't people like you don't what now you're thinking who would have it out for me huh a few weeks back there might have been a station wagon in the forest full of all sorts of food water things you need to survive yeah I'm not some cannibal thee some killer out in the woods some villain I'm just a dad I coach little league I didn't take from you yeah I didn't people didn't I didn't agree with it that's true Clementine said why didn't you because it wasn't right it wasn't right it wasn't our stuff that's real good of you look what do you want me to say i don't want you to say anything i want you to know what happened have you ever hurt somebody you care about so did you eat them yes yes of course who wife my wife Clementine said she wasn't with you I heard her a long time ago how oh it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you say so I heard her so bad my son Adam went missing I took him out hunting even though my wife said he was too young I figured he had to learn oh I came back without him and the look on her face said you are a monster we all went out looking for him uh-huh we never found him oh I heard her so bad what how did you lose him And all our stuff was gone.
Oh.
Your people, Lee.
That asshole in the ball cap.
His stupid fucking wife.
I could have earned her trust back if they hadn't made our situation so desperate.
Well, how'd you know it was us?
We'll be empathetic.
I'm sorry.
The hungrier we got, the more she blamed me.
We're trying to get Claire.
until she finally took our daughter Elizabeth and left okay they didn't get far I found them a day later a day in the road do I look like a monster to you yeah kind of um we all do we all do some more than others oh you gonna you Are you gonna say you look worse than me?
Or I look worse than you?
You killed a man with a pitchfork right in front of a little girl.
Uh, I protected her.
I did what I had to.
You abandoned a defenseless, grieving woman.
She deserved it.
You weren't there.
You brought her to the most dangerous place in this city where she could have died.
Uh.
That's not the whole story.
Yeah, this guy...
The whole story?
This guy is, like, trying to be a therapist, judging our actions throughout the game.
How could you know all this?
Yeah, he only knows 50% of the story.
The iDroid.
You're a monster.
You're a murderer and a thief.
And I'm gonna hurt you so bad.
Oh, don't threaten me with a good time.
I didn't steal from you!
But think of everything else you did.
For survival!
Clementine on my radio.
I wasn't even mad at you.
I was coming for the others.
For revenge.
Go after them then!
The things you did.
Clementine is...
Clementine...
Girl, what are you telling people about me?
This before what happens next.
I can take care of her.
We can have a family.
Oh, like you took care of your son, huh?
I bet you don't even know how old she is.
Isn't she seven?
She's eight.
Wrong.
What?
She's nine.
But her birthday was six days ago.
Oh, well, um...
I know how to be a dad, you know.
She wouldn't be exposed to what she has.
I was wrong completely.
you're crazy no no we're just gonna say yeah it makes sense no it's not happening no i'm bitten and you you'll have to let us go let us go no no i don't think so you're going away and we're starting a new family no no hey honey i think this is all gonna work out What are you...
School days?
I'm glad too.
Nice.
I wish you wouldn't have had to get this bad, but it's all over, hun.
Isn't it?
Just about.
I hate seeing you like this.
I just miss your smile, honey.
It's school days!
I miss you so much, Tess.
You're gonna like Clementine a lot, though.
She's not Lizzie, but she's sweet.
wouldn't hurt a fly.
Yeah!
Uh-oh.
He's fast.
Oh, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q.
Oh, gosh.
Hey!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh.
I'm cueing, I'm queuing, I'm queuing, I'm queuing, I'm queuing, and nothing's happening.
Oh, my gosh.
It's the slowest.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to kill them, but, well, I guess I have to.
Oh, whatever.
Q.
Q for kill.
Q for kill, Q for kill.
Oh, I think he's dead.
Never mind.
He's got some strength still in him.
Son of a bitch.
Just go away.
You!
Clem with the headshot.
I...
.
Oh.
It's okay.
you
look horrible that's what he said let's just get somewhere safe you don't smell good oh yeah i know i haven't oh god did i smell like did he hurt you did he hurt you no not really i'm sorry lee clayham it's okay we need to get you somewhere safe and then we have to talk Right orange?
Oh my gosh.
Everything's okay now.
We need to figure out how to get out of Savannah as fast as we can.
Well, how many are in there?
Hey.
You weren't afraid.
I was.
You didn't act like it.
I know.
I am now.
It's okay.
Can she get a happy birthday?
Right!
My gosh.
which way out through there okay that's the way we came in right you okay yeah but i want to go okay we'll go we'll go you okay yeah but i want to go
oh my god she's still alive jesus don't look in there i know oh my god you were He was keeping a zombie head around her.
Which leads to the other home.
There's nothing in there.
Can we go?
Yeah, of course.
Okay.
I'm just looking around.
Any food?
Any anything?
Look at stranger.
Oh, him.
I don't even know his name.
Norman Bates.
Dolahan.
It's kind of awesome.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, I think I clicked look at it.
Yeah, let's go.
Hopefully the gunshot didn't attract people.
Boom!
Oh, he smells like a zombie now.
He smells like a zombie now!
It didn't bite you.
Yeah, I know it must have you're covered in all that gross stuff Oh to get through a bunch of them to get here.
Yeah Maybe okay, never mind I thought it was because he was Zombo.
Okay, it's because he's covered in Zombo blood
Oh We're gonna be real stinky now Clem Who do Zombo?
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I meant to do.
They smell horrible.
Which means you have to, too.
Okay.
She understands.
She knows.
Oh, no.
Oh, fragrance of Zombo.
I'm gonna scoop up some of that guy.
Oh, yeah.
Ew!
All right.
Smear Clementine.
Me too.
Ew.
Is this so horrible?
Are you okay?
We'll get you cleaned up as soon as we can.
Not soon enough.
She's alright.
The sound.
Are you done?
A little more.
I want to be sure.
Not the face.
Don't get the face.
Just a little more.
Don't get...
It's so gross.
Don't get the face.
I mean, is the whisper we say from the zombies?
I think you guys smell good probably.
There.
That should do it.
She makes it sound cold.
You know, like...
I hope so.
Like if you're putting like a cold lotion on your body.
I thought it was gone.
Her heart!
I thought you were gone.
Thank you.
Probably is.
You think so?
Stay right next to me.
Walk very slowly.
Don't look around.
And don't panic.
That's just like the TV show.
I'll keep you safe.
Probably cool since the zombies are dead.
I guess that's true.
I didn't think about it.
There we go.
Uh-oh.
Sounds like it's gonna rain.
Oh,
we gotta go before it washes off our body.
Yeah, Lee's looking real pale.
I thought that too.
Easy does it.
Just push him away if you have to.
Oh, hello.
Excuse me.
Oh, we're filming here.
Okay.
everybody's got to get their chance in the spotlight they're like I'm in the movie
don't make a noise leave I'm gonna you guys no no it's not
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
We're parents.
Oh, more baby.
Lee,
wake up.
Please don't be dead.
Please no.
Oh, how'd she get him in here?
Oh, he looks really bad.
Oh, God, he looks so bad.
you left me I I saw my parents come here sweetie oh they're dead they really are
oh we have to get out of here as fast as we can oh we can't it looks there's thousands of them outside we have to i'll protect you we'll push no that's crazy i saved you we're safe here i us in.
Get that door open.
I can't!
Do it!
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
It was only a little open when I found it.
I closed it to keep us safe.
How did she pull him in here?
A grown man deadweight!
Two, three!
Yeah!
adrenaline I guess so see oh Clem Clementine honey what what happened no no no that's that's not no no no no no yes Clem it is it's gonna be okay okay you we just have to think and work together okay
oh I think there might be a way out over there oh security good good girl let's go might be a little slow I'll help you oh gosh
yeah he's looking like a real security guard right now I got you.
You can lean on me if you have to.
I'm okay.
I thought I was helping by bringing you in here.
It's okay.
You couldn't have known, yeah.
You couldn't have known.
I should have told you.
It was scary at the hotel.
Yeah.
Keep going.
We're almost there.
Okay.
We're going to keep going.
What is it?
is this place anyway jewelry store oh get up lee the door is right here
oh i can't you have to then i can't move this is it for me here please no please try to get up
I can't.
You don't have much time.
You've got to do something.
Fast.
Like what?
Uh, you need to get out of here.
You need to get out of here.
Make sure I don't turn.
I can't leave you.
Just work on getting out, okay?
We'll figure it all out.
Don't worry.
The way out's through there, Clem.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
Okay, you gotta go.
Just start by getting that door open.
Okay, we'll help her out.
It's locked.
It's no big deal.
It's just a glass window.
Oh.
Ow!
Not with your hand.
Use this thing.
Or use, uh, this thing.
There's a chair over there.
Uh, use...
a baseball bat.
There you go.
You can use that.
How did he see that?
I didn't even see that.
You can do it to Larry.
Okay, base...
Use the bat to shadow that window so you can reach in, okay?
Okay.
Watch out for broken grass.
Oh.
Don't be afraid of him, honey.
You're smart.
He is it.
Why is he stuck to the chair?
Yeah, you're doing good.
The way out's through there, Clem.
I know.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, there's a chair.
Use it.
There you go.
Use it to reach in to the log.
Be careful!
It's a rolly chair!
Wow, that thing is clean of glass, huh?
Good thing.
He's trapped.
This will be easy, then.
He's got keys.
Probably to that door.
Oh, yeah.
And everything you'll need.
Why don't you hit him in the head with the bat, maybe?
You're doing really good.
Another handcuff, son of Ralph.
Get him.
me I don't think we can handcuff him but
she needs to get the keys I guess she can use the bat put the handcuffs on me attach me to this what why
I don't know.
Just do it, sweetie.
Make sure they're tight.
I don't want to do this.
You have to.
It'll keep you safe.
You only have to deal with him.
He's trapped over there.
So careful.
Get what you need from him.
The keys.
And then the gun.
The keys and the gun.
Just don't be afraid.
If anything gets dangerous, you're faster than he is.
Yeah.
What should I get first?
Get the gun.
Uh, get the gun.
Get the gun, Clem.
Always the gun.
Uh.
Oh my gosh.
Get him.
Uh.
Grab it.
or that yeah watch out oh my god there's nothing we can do the bat oh i got it i got it i got it
oh my god yeah yeah
i did it i got
it great job oh we got it's a are we oh hey
you're strong cliff you you can do anything but i'm little no doesn't mean nothing you go see bad stuff but it's okay my parents it's so I can't imagine this would be.
And now...
You...
Please...
Please don't be one of them.
Please don't become a walker.
There's only one thing you can do.
You know that.
I don't know if I can.
Oh, gosh.
I have to decide.
Uh...
You have to shoot me, honey.
Lee, no.
It's okay.
And Megan, those days we met, do you remember?
Yeah, I do.
When I went out to rescue that boy, Claire, I met a girl.
She'd been bitten, too.
All she wanted was to come back as a walker.
And I remember how hard it was to do that.
But I'm glad I did.
You don't want to see me like one of them.
Okay, Lee.
I can do it.
I can.
Find that if I don't meet it, Krista.
If I don't meet it, Krista.
They're outside of town by the train.
You remember how to get back there?
Yes.
Good.
Oh, she'll remember this.
Now take good care of you.
And glim...
You're a suit.
You can always keep moving.
Wait, I tried to do the hair!
I'm gonna find some place like the motor in, but that's just not safe.
Why not?
Those places are just targets.
Move as much as you can.
And also...
Oh my god.
I wanted to do the hair.
I messed up.
What?
What is it?
No, don't worry.
All right.
Don't be afraid.
Wait,
when did I lose my temper with Kenny?
You have 40% of players kept your weapons.
I didn't even use them, though.
Killed Clementine's captor.
Wait, I tried to.
What do you mean I didn't kill him?
I tried.
Oh, throwing the statue.
Oh, I forgot that it's an option to, like, not do that.
Or like to not do anything.
Yeah, Clem did it, but I tried.
I tried to kill him.
Man, you and 28% of players didn't remove your arm.
So most people remove their arm?
Wow.
It wouldn't have mattered.
I don't think so either.
It was so much time after the bite had happened.
It literally happened like in the day.
They would have had to grab you maybe seconds later, cut off your arm immediately.
Let's see the...
Oh.
Oh, wow.
You found water for Duck when he needed it.
He was lost to the herd trying to save Ben.
Larry died in the meat locker.
Where you belong?
You were separated after you crossed the sign.
Yeah.
Oh, me it's the only one smiling.
You left her on the side of the road.
Ben fell to his death in a savannah alleyway You defended her against Lily's accusations And she died for it You asked her and Omiya to take care of them and die No, dog You had so much more I like how Ben is only two little things When he was with us for so many episodes
You let him be your sidekicks Solve a mystery Oh.
Ben caused most of these deaths.
He really did.
Oh.
So there's something after the credits that she meet with.
Oh my gosh, it's a good thing we didn't tell.
Kenny thought we wanted him to take care of her of Clem Beacons
Last years and The trail Take us back off take us back off I guess I'll wait for the aftersane.
Yeah, Ben took out Kenny's whole family, man.
Got me again this time.
Like I knew that.
was gonna be inevitable because of the last episode but ah just yeah it sucks voice actors in this game are so good of
days when love was true
No.
Just beyond the silent surface.
Started in cuffs, died in cuffs.
I didn't think about that.
Me!
Oh my gosh, the pets!
I love when they do this.
Peekaboo the cat!
And me!
So sad.
Oh, okay.
Glam!
Me too.
Did Krista and Omid make it?
Yeah.
what is that batteries oh no they're they're shells did he teach her how to reload the gun he taught her how to shoot but wait is it zombo no that's not zombo that's too tall to be omid
is it them
it's kind of creepy They could...
They could wave.
Oh!
It's them, right?
It's Kenny and Ben.
And then her seeing her parents.
Oh.
Why did they go back?
It's Doug and Larry.
Oh.
They almost didn't put Clementine in the game because they couldn't find the right actor for her.
Let's be thankful for Clem's voice actors beautifully voicing her.
How would you have this without Clem?
No, all the actors were really amazing.
Oh.
And then there's this DLC, right?
the 400 days.
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot he was in the game.
Whatever his name was.
Glenn?
Will you play other Telltale games?
I would like to.
A lot of people have been recommending Borderlands and I think there's a Batman one.
I was looking at one of them yesterday.
For the other seasons of this him i'll think about it um i really liked this one but uh my hesitation with the other seasons uh or yeah other seasons is just i've heard mixed reviews from literally everybody about every single one so i'm kind of like hesitant i've heard i've heard season two is great and i've heard season two is bad and i've heard season three is okay and i've heard season three is terrible and i've heard season four is all right i've heard season four so i really don't i'm not quite sure yet i will consider it though i will think about it oh that was so sad
but i'll think about it because to play the whole thing would be quite an undertaking
So, I will never say never, but, you know, I will, I'll think about it.
Oh yeah, and then the Wolf Among Us, yeah, I was looking at that one too.
For good laughs, see the Telltale Batman with the animations removed.
Oh, Moogus?
Do you guys see that Among Us is doing a Genshin Impact collab?
What is going on in that game?
Members watch along of three of the three Back to the Future.
Then you play Telltale Back to the Future.
Wait, it's also Back to the Future's 40th anniversary.
Why?
I have no idea.
What about Among Us?
Uh...
Strong bad game.
You're watching it in theaters?
What?
Back to the future?
I've only seen
the first one.
Did I watch the second one?
What happens in the second one?
I can't remember.
Strong bad.
strong bad emails
they go back from the future he goes to the future maybe i only watch the first one then because i watched it actually i think what it was is i because i watched it really for the first time relatively recently and i watched it and it was on the plane and i think the plane only had like one and three?
Or it might have been just one and two.
And I feel like I would have watched both of them then.
But I don't remember the second one at all.
Ah.
Man, my head hurts from crying.
Hold on, where's my water?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
We really ended the game.
Oh, well, Clementine had kind of like a I feel like if Clem died, the game was over kind of deal.
So Clem doesn't count, but...
If I hadn't killed...
Or if I had killed Ben, would Kenny have survived?
Be honest.
Be honest with me.
Team.
If I had...
No?
Oh, okay.
he dies in a different way okay okay okay he sacrifices himself for krista instead oh i felt like that i feel like that is that's a more worthy cause i thought i honestly after the boat being taken all i hope vernon and his crew i hope i hope they drown but um for for uh what's it called for kenny after the boat was taken i feel like he just kind of was he was like no there's no hope left 400 days shows what happens to them oh does it maybe i'm we'll play that then is that like a one is that like how long is 400 days wait one second oh dlc
it's short it's 400 days
okay let's see from day one of the undead plague to 400 days later the walking dead 400 days offers more of the horror and human drama of robert kirkley and telltales award-winning series well he lives if you're not died did me leaving duck hanging change nothing um uh i want to look at the pictures
is that like a bunch of different people it seems like
Oh, I'm so sad.
It's all your fault.
Keep telling yourself that.
It's a bunch of one shots.
Okay, okay.
Man.
I feel like...
Okay, okay.
Now I'm seeing the season two.
I tried not to look before.
I figured...
I was like, Clementine's probably gonna live.
But...
I realized she became like the pro tag for the rest of the games.
Okay.
I'm seeing now.
Don't look.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Don't look.
I'm literally just hovered over.
I can't.
I'm sorry.
Guys, this is what I see.
The steam is spoiling it for me.
Wait, hold on.
Steam, literally Steam spoiled it for me.
I had, it was like, buy the Walking Dead collection.
And then it said, Walking Dead final season.
And Clem's face is on it, okay?
I didn't, I didn't do anything.
It's Steam.
Maybe it's not Clem.
the same hat that's definitely her that's her 100% but she's she's it's totally her look at this hold on I'll show you I'll show you what it shows me all done let me actually screenshot it there we go okay hold on steam steam.png this is what it shows me this is what it shows me look at that How could I...
Walking Dead, the final season.
She's right there.
It's her evil twin.
I'm imagining an alternate version where they don't find Clem's VA and end up pointing the series to Lee being a father figure for Ben.
That could be anyone.
She's wearing the hat.
That hat is Clem's walk-a-moment.
the protag torch it was him being like him doing the little tutorial for her him backseating her no that is not Clem oh I don't feel good though I feel actually very sad I'm glad though that he didn't turn if I had said leave instead of shoot would she leave or would she be like no I can't do it so sad oh she does she just leaves Wow she really would leave Wow well
now she knows that he is not a zombie you can also tell her to avoid people and she ends up alone
Aww.
I wanted to tell her about keeping her hair short.
My one regret.
No wonder I'm a ghost.
Oh.
Kenny.
Aww.
Hope you had a fun time.
Thanks for letting me relive the game.
I really do want to do, like, a route where I'm just a jerk to everybody.
I just want to see what happens.
Oh, well, thank you so much for the good thing I have to thank you.
Thank you.
Bully Maguire, yeah.
Scumbag lead playthrough videos are hilarious.
but I wanted to do like a proper playthrough of what I would actually pick rather than just you know rather than just causing shit starting shit being a little bit of a menace
the final Clementine will remember that she would happily probably shoot me she would probably happily shoot me and then and then that's that
but you are a menace yeah but i felt this game was a little too serious to be so i wanted to since it was my first time experiencing it it's really fun to be a jerk to everyone in the wolf among us okay this one this one i heard was sad so i was like okay i'll i'll play it serious but mischief minto But with other ones,
you know, I like to be a little bit of a troublemaker.
I got married yesterday!
So by law, they're your wife, too.
Moonekin!
Congratulations!
We got married!
What if in my asshole playthrough, I actually high-five duck?
It's the one ounce of kindness that I have.
This was much shorter than I thought it would be, actually.
Not the game itself, but this chapter.
I can't believe the guy that kidnapped her was the guy from the car.
What a...
What?
What a weenie.
First, you have your kid go missing.
Why weren't you watching your kid?
What happened?
And then...
Your wife and daughter leave you, but you're gonna be like, oh, I'm all better than you.
I kidnapped this girl, but you were just trying to survive.
I just...
I...
It's...
It's so bizarre.
Dude is blaming everyone but himself.
Yeah!
He didn't want to admit his own mistakes.
What?
It was just so bizarre.
I mean, we already knew he was loony because he kept his wife's head in a bag.
He had already lost it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it wasn't exactly stable, huh?
But...
But also, just so strange.
So strange.
I don't know what I would do if I were, you know, in an apocalypse and I saw a car that was abandoned full of food I mean, I might assume that they got turned into zombos, right?
Do you have any recommendations for cafes and stuff in Ikebukuro?
Sorry, I was asking if I feel bad for...
Oh, yes, thank you, Garlamal, thank you, thank you.
Stuff in Ikebukuro.
Yes, yes, yes.
No, don't feel bad at all because I said remind me later.
Oh gosh, there was a place I went to, um, where, what was it?
There was a place in Ikebukuro I went to before.
Oh, so there's, um, uh, there's a Capcom cafe in Ikebukuro that is fun to go to.
Um, last time I went, they were doing the Great Ace Attorney, a collab with that game.
and then um there's also a uh it's in the same building as the capcom cafe it's it's like a what was it it's a bread place i don't remember the name at all but um they come around and they they bake all the bread themselves and they come around and they give you like different types of bread um just like they just walk to your table or just like they'll be like do you want to try this bread and you can go and you can buy the bread and stuff it was really really good um uh i wish i knew the name of it i'm so sorry it's in the same building as the capcom cafe the um yeah so much bread so much bread hold on let me see you know what i'll look it up myself i have a i'm i'm smart I have a computer Let's see Ikebukuro Capcom Cafe And then let's see what The building name is Okay Uh Here Okay Uh This is plaza No that's Uh There's also a Movie theater in there Um Okay hold on Uh Uh Is it this one No,
that's a diner.
I wish I could see what this building is called.
Oh, Grandscape Ikebukuro.
Grandscape Ikebukuro.
I can research myself.
I'm not helpless, like Ben.
Apparently there's a Burger King in there.
Yeah, there's another, like, it's kind of like they say it's a capcom uh like gotcha store like gotcha place but
but like it wasn't just capcom themed so you could still go in it was just really crowded and i thought i would get like some devil may cry things but they unfortunately did not have not tollies is it this e One pan...
Yes!
The espresso EDW Dwerks.
What is it?
Espresso...
Wait, let me see.
Wait.
Hold on.
Espresso EDW.
I can't look at all.
I have to see the inside.
If I see the inside, I'll know it.
Ah, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Espresso Dwerks.
Dwerks.
I guess it's also an espresso place.
I liked it.
It was good.
It was quite good.
I had the spaghetti and it was spicy and that made me a little sad.
But actually it was...
Okay, I told the story before.
But it was here.
I was with a friend.
And which...
No, I won't say.
I was with a friend.
And we were both...
going to go to a Hollow Live concert together because we got an invitation to go watch and we were like, okay, we'll go we'll travel together and we messaged a third friend that was going to come with us and the third friend was just like, oh yeah, she was like,
what do you mean today?
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
And we were like, tomorrow.
No, it's today.
And,
and, and we were like, wait, no, it's today.
And, we were in Ike Bukuro.
We, if you Google Ike Bukuro to Saitama, it's about a 40 minute train ride.
And so right after we were eating this, we were going to get on the train to go to Saitama because it was at And we were like, wait, if it's tomorrow, okay, if it's tomorrow, wait, what did I, did I say, wait, so she was saying, it's not today, it's tomorrow,
and I was like, yeah, wait, no, we were like, no, it's today, and she was like, no, it's tomorrow, and, yeah, it was Gamers Fest, yeah, yeah, yeah, and both my friend and I were just like, wait, how did we both get the date wrong?
How did we both get the date wrong?
And we were both going to go to this event that was not even happening this day.
We were going to travel 40 minutes away to go to this concert that was not happening.
And unfortunately, on that day, the day after, so the tomorrow that we were going to go to the concert, was me flying back home so in the end i didn't even get to go i was so sad i was so sad was it provided to you wrong or something nope no she and i just had the same brain cell she and i just had the same brain cell so we were like why we're how did we both mess this up cut it in friday night
Oh, yeah, we both really messed it up.
She was still able to go, though, and I really wanted the pen light, and she picked it up for me, so I'm happy, happy.
So, yeah, espresso D works Ike Bukuro.
My recommendation.
The bread is really good.
And they just come around, and they're like, would you like to try this bread?
And I was like, yeah, give me more bread.
Give me more bread.
Friendship wins in the end.
Yeah, she's so sweet.
I love her.
So, um, yeah.
But, unfortunately, I don't know so many other places in Ikebukuro.
Um, unfortunately, I do not.
I only go a little bit.
I don't like going to that area because it's like, um, because it's such a, like, uh, like, uh, how do you say?
Like there's Otome Road and everything.
There's a lot of girls.
Because there's a lot of girls.
girls there's also a lot of guys who like to like to nampa and so um not red light district no no no but like sometimes the guys will be very aggressive and they'll like follow you to your train and i'm like go away go away uh otaku guys in akihabara don't bother me They're not interested.
So, only at Ikebukuro.
I'm anime woman, but I'm not from their anime, you know.
2D only.
I mean, I am, but I'm not from something that they're interested in.
No.
so one too many dimensions once I become once I become 3D now then they'll never talk to me ever again ever ever Nampa Horde be like the walkers in the episode there's like and it's not even just me like it happening to me like I see it happening to people and I'm like ugh ugh Or like to my friends,
I'm like, Ah, stay away from her!
She's mine!
2D over 3D girls.
Yeah!
So, yeah, back, you beasts.
I need to walk around with like a chair that like keeps them away, you know?
Anyway, this was, was this fun?
It was fun.
I'm glad I played it.
I'm very sad I played it.
I could have gone my whole afterlife not playing it.
But, hmm.
It was good storytelling.
Yeah.
It was.
We.
We, I tried to keep it live.
I tried to do it with these types.
of games anyway you know i make jokes ben died 10 out of 10 what a what a pathetic way to die
oh speaking of weenies the guy in the hotel is a weenie ben just thanks for the stream thank you
just man
man bad day to be named ben not you the walking dead telltale games ben but not every other ben not ben any ben in the chat you're awesome every ben in the chat is great ben's my co-worker okay that guy i can't vouch for ben died as he lived complaining and making it someone else's problem.
I just think, you know, in this, in these kinds of situations, and everybody was guilty of this.
I'll, I'll say that.
Everybody was very guilty of this, but you kind of gotta, you know, if you're in a group, you gotta think of the group, you know, and Ben was never a team player, as much as he wanted to be.
He, he would always be like, I have my own problems too, but everyone has their literally it's an apocalypse everybody's going through it you kind of just have to like you know you kind of gotta be like okay i i i gotta i gotta you guys just have to pull it together you actually have to oh my gosh scuba i'm not named ben but can you tell me i'm awesome yeah you're awesome everybody's awesome you're all awesome
the bandits off the group's back yes but like he was trading their resources and not he didn't explain that to anybody either because because he didn't communicate with the team if they had known that he was if he had if he had this deal if if if they had known he had this deal like then what's her name what was her name lily lily i think it was she wouldn't have been like i'm i'm paranoid now and then and then it wouldn't have sparked lead to go find the missing medicines and take it and then the deal fell through and then they got attacked
the attack would have happened i mean maybe the the hotel was not a great place to be we can i think we can all agree with that they would have left sooner yeah they needed to but also it was like kenny was trying to leave it was lily that was holding him back
so i know ben was a kid i know and i know a lot of people say try to like be like don't be so teenager just kind of going you know i can't say how i would be i don't know i'm dead anyway so but but but it's a doggy dog world and you either you either pull your shit together or you get the entire crew killed that's kind of how it goes
It's just the sad part of it.
A doggy dog world.
Kids shouldn't have acted independently.
I mean.
Unfortunately.
He probably thought he had the, you know, the crew's best interest.
He was trying to get the bandits off of them.
But we also saw how the bandits were for like the other people that they made deals with.
So, making a deal with them in the first place is not a good idea, I think.
I think it's just better to leave.
Doggy dog world.
It's freak or get freaked, my man.
I'm freaking it.
I choose to freak it, I think.
Clementine handled herself a lot better than most adults in the game.
She's a, she's a, she's a, maybe, I think someone called her an anomaly before though.
She freaked it.
I freaked it.
Ben tried his best, and that's more than most did.
Ben did try.
Did he, well, he, uh, well, you know, Clementine was about to get attacked and he ran.
Um.
if you try to save larry kenny calls you useless and does it anyway he then picks fights with you for two to three episodes no matter how friendly you are really
i i did get some comments from people being like oh i'm used to kenny being a real jerk so um i mean i think it's very safe to say no none of these characters were perfect But that's...
That's realistic.
That's realistic, you know?
I do think that a lot of decisions were questionable.
And a lot of options and dialogues were questionable.
But Ben tried to die a couple of times.
Yeah.
Do you disagree with him?
Like, once or twice he's very combative.
Oh, geez.
That would have been miserable.
Except Molly.
She's perfect.
Oh, me and I liked him a lot.
I'm glad he lived.
He ended up being so silly.
He was just a silly guy.
He was funny.
Kenny's kind of miserable.
Yeah.
I wonder what all these people would be like not in an apocalypse.
You know?
Hmm.
Like, Kenny, I've totally only looked out for his own.
Uh...
Yeah.
Larry would be the same.
Larry is a miserable piece of doo-doo.
Battery girl.
Uh, Carly.
It's kind of the sad thing about Kenny's hypocrisy.
I know, like, he's such a bro.
And then at the same time, you're like, Kenny.
Kenny, we can't just...
Oh, oh, he's just like, I gotta look out for my family.
And you're like, oh, Kenny, Kenny, come on.
I need you to reason with me a little bit, buddy.
I need you to reason with me a little bit.
We lost, like, like, losing Carly was a huge hit because she was super rational.
And, uh,
yeah, he's a real character.
Exactly, exactly.
Hmm.
What makes a person is their ability to change.
but like you know i kind of said earlier like i like that you know with kenny you could be like hey man this and he'd be like i know you know like he wasn't perfect he really he was far from perfect but you know he had some rational thought dog would have found the cure the g he was on the verge of a breakthrough he was like tomorrow tomorrow is the day that i'll figure out how to how to cure this terrible infection the
cure was the turns out the cure was to be a chill guy i don't understand though why isn't everyone always covering themselves in in zombo rot then if that's just how you get through them like as soon as i learn that i would be going everywhere head to toe like covered in in in whatever whatever comes out of them you'd get used to it do you guys realize how stinky people were back in like days when they didn't like like people what was it oh gosh like before baths were considered like good people just stank so bad i think it's the same
in the show someone gets deathly ill from it oh well you know all you have to do okay hear me out you don't have to be covered all the time but all you have to do is find if you're like okay i gotta go out i gotta go get supplies find one guy kill him rub it all over your body And then you come back,
and then you're just like, okay, let the river fall down, and wash me clean, and then you're fine.
That's all you gotta do.
I think I would survive.
I've got it all figured out.
Anyways, this was a lot of fun, you guys.
Thank you for joining me for The Walking Dead.
if i decide to play the other games it won't be like you know next week or anything but we'll see we'll see we'll see um thank you thank you have a good day have a good night have a good time zone and i will see you when i see you next oh i need to get some water in me crying so much i was i was already crying so bad when they were like walking through the...
Like as soon as they left the hotel, it was just...
Okay.
What's up, y'all?
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.